and now here's something neat that i
wanted you all to see take a look
hi drew it's liz of e cake be mary and i
want to share with you how to create
these adorable puppy cupcakes
first you'll want to shape some fondant
to create the ears eyes tongue and nose
then color some buttercream and place
them into piping bags
now grab a cupcake and using a grass tip
pipe lines that extend from the center
out
go ahead and cover the entire surface of
the cupcake with fur
once you've done that let's create some
of the puppies facial features
now you can add both ears angle them
just a little
two eyes
a cute nose and of course a pink tongue
let's add some twinkle to those precious
puppy eyes
so adorable isn't it just the cutest
let's bring in some friends
there you have a fun and easy way to
create the cutest cupcakes
hi drew it's papi ginich to help
celebrate hispanic heritage month i'm
going to make a salsa matcha and it's
gorgeous and so delicious it's from my
upcoming book treasures of the mexican
table and to make it all you need is
five minutes and you can use it in so
many ways so i'm gonna add olive oil
vegetable oil once it's hot add walnuts
pine nuts pistachios garlic cloves ancho
chilies stem them sit them cut them into
small pieces
and chill is the herbal you're gonna
stem them i'm gonna keep the seeds
and then i'm gonna stir
our pumpkin seeds amaranth seeds vinegar
dark brown sugar salt mix these up
and we're gonna let it cool you can
spoon it on top of avocado toast you can
spoon it on top of pancakes french toast
you can spoon it on top of yogurt fruit
you can eat it in so many ways it's
super young
hi drew i'm capri lilly creator of good
food baddie and today i'll be showing
you how to make these spooky pumpkin ice
cream cookie sandwiches here i have
homemade double chocolate chip cookies
and they're going to serve as the base
for our pumpkin ice cream cookie
sandwiches right now i'm going to show
you how to make your own pumpkin ice
cream at home i'm going to start off by
adding the pumpkin puree
then i'll add coconut cream maple syrup
pumpkin spice cinnamon coconut sugar and
blend until it's smooth then i'll place
in the bread pan and place it in the
freezer for two hours and now i have
this delicious smooth creamy pumpkin
spiced nice cream now we'll take a scoop
of the ice cream
and place it on top of our double
chocolate chip cookies
and then use another cookie
to finish and complete the sandwich and
we're all done we have these spooky
pumpkin spice ice cream cookie
sandwiches
[Music]